this your new pack how's that feel I
[Music]
started smoking when I was 13
seeing my dad holding a cigarette
buffing you know it'd be in my room and
I would hold my coloring pencils and
I'll pretend that I'm holding a
cigarette start smoking from 1316 and
then I took a year off and then from 17
to now which I'm 26
then 2017 I decided to quit haven't been
smoking for almost a month now quitting
cold turkey been the biggest achievement
of 2017 I snuck a cigarette I was out
with my friends and I just took a
cigarette out I thought that I would be
in control I would be in control of my
mind I'm not gonna fall in a pit of
protection it was wrong because one
after another after another I ended up
buying a pack and here we are still
smoking hi my name is rocky Rosen I'm
called the cigarette whisperer I get
people off tobacco off of whether
they're smoking or vaping I can have
anybody smoke-free in three days no
tricks no gimmicks I started smoking I
was 13 at 22 I sounded like I was 85
first time I help anybody stop smoking
was in 1991 I got the name - cigarette
Whisperer from a doctor in Beverly Hills
I got a person off cigarette then I got
another person off cigarettes doctors
started to used means I probably helped
over a thousand people get smoked free
I'm ROH hi nice to meet you it's me -
got two questions for you
do you smoke I do do you wish you didn't
yes
all right good the reason why I want to
quit smoking is that I start realizing
health problems I start coughing at
night sometimes running out of breath
it's bothering me because I'm only 26 I
think I've tried to quit smoking on a
daily basis I bet I can have you
smoke-free by our third session
completely and you'll be ready okay this
I can call this [ __ ] until it
happens right to be quite honest I'm
skeptical a little bit about this whole
method so I'm not sure I don't know what
to expect but I want it to work if
you're jonesing for a cigarette doing
this let's take a break go have a
cigarette
okay the program I teach is kind of
taken from Albert Ellis Albert Ellis was
a psychologist he wrote a book called
rational cognitive therapy it doesn't
seem to be going away but you keep
trying to fight it it keeps getting
bigger and bigger if you have something
going on why don't you learn how to use
the urges instead of always trying to
fight the urge don't deny what you feel
lean into it
the tobacco industry has been brilliant
hiding the truth about nicotine in
dictionaries nicotine is an insecticide
so when you smoke or when you vape the
very best you're doing is you're just
spraying hot insecticide down your
throat I once that treaters off but you
know what I kept white and back up and I
couldn't figure that out because I knew
I was screwed by smoking
I would cop if I laugh at cough if I
walked up steps at cop if I was sitting
I'd cough if I was being intimate it's
all sounds familiar to me some of my
friends smoked occasionally where they
don't get affected they just smoke when
they can or when they want yeah that
would be great because every stop
smoking methodology out there that's
available back when I stopped and even
today is all designed to try to make the
urge of smoke go away for those of us
who gotten addicted the urge never does
totally go away now that makes nothing
very plain to you I don't care when you
do where you do it why you do it how you
do it when you quit smoking you have
some discomfort to expect but the truth
is you're already uncomfortable and the
truth is the discomfort of not smoking
is so much better than this comfort you
get by smoking I always tell my clients
you know you and I may or may not agree
on much but I do think that we can both
agree that you deserve better than all
that crap two big lies about quitting
smoking why not more when I gotta quit
smoking ever tell yourself I gotta quit
smoking oh yeah everything every day for
how long for the past year but what do
you still do I go buy a pack you don't
have to quit cigarettes are available
there's nobody alive we're gonna tell
you whether you can smoke or not but you
never have to stop smoking
why number two I don't want to smoke
anymore how I can turn yourself I don't
want to smoke anymore
for a year even more but what do you
still do uncle says well you knowing
that you're still gonna want to smoke
even after you stop smoking that's I'm
gonna get your cigarettes
Juanita's smoke isn't the problem it's a
person's condition smoking is what
causes problems if we're gonna work
together you're still gonna have
cigarettes even after you quit smoking
you're gonna have a pack handy I know
that seems what that's nuts what Amuro
has to expect is he's gonna learn how to
start smoking from a place of
consciousness instead of just lighting
up whenever he wants to he's gonna be
aware of what he's doing
why do I have to
carry a pack with me what do you think
about when you have cigarettes with you
I want to smell quite no you don't think
that all the time you think about
everything else in a cigarette thought
occur to you but will you have no
cigarettes we just get focused and
that's that's why but plus you can't get
rid of them they're all around you
the single biggest obstacle we smokers
have at getting smoke free it's finding
a way to overcome this feeling of
deprivation when I want a cigarette but
I feel like I can't have it because I
had to stop or I gotta quit do you want
to know the only reason why you smoke
you smoke to make the urge to summer go
away it's the only reason why we smoke
that's cuz you don't want the other
should be there he smoked and the Jones
and as a result you're jonesing all the
time so we wanted you before we get you
off cigarettes it's teach you how you
can offset deprivation is by coming from
the truth this is all on point so I'm
gonna give you this card I want you to
write the word benefits here let's talk
about some of the benefits you may want
how about better health absolutely write
down better health I'm not just telling
your physical health impaired your
mental health your emotional health your
intimate oh how about a better life
absolutely how about just to feel better
I've got more energy how about for my
family how about freedom yes yes look at
these words that put a super-pac what do
they say I'm nicotine addicted I want to
smoke I can smoke I don't have to stop
think about your benefits make them
large and powerful so I'm gonna ask you
to do starting now is before you light
eat any cigarettes
as you say these words first are you
capable of doing that yes do you deserve
better than what sit what you're doing
for you yes can you say these words
before you light a cigarette yes we read
the notes over before I talk to you for
the next session yes do you have any
questions no okay I'm honestly very
overwhelmed because what he said it was
things that I usually tell myself I just
didn't believe it I didn't want to push
myself even though like they already say
smoking kills it's not resonating as
much as remembering all the things that
means a lot to use maybe I'm not gonna
stop but I think these words gonna do a
lot of change I think constantly my mind
gonna remember that I have the freedom
to do it but I decided not to I'm
excited to see what if this is the first
session what is it gonna be the second
in the third
oh god how are you I'm in the middle of
the session right now
and he asked me to go and have my last
cigarette it's a good bike as to an
abusive relationship so I'm having my
last one - thanks for ruining my
thirteen past my thirteen years of life
and I'm gonna read the words and my last
one day one and I didn't wake up at 4
a.m. because of coughing this is the
first night I just slept throughout the
night and I just woke up I guess this is
working some of my friends he's having a
little house party I want to smoke so
bad everyone I know is looking the
balcony right now smoking but right now
I'm just hiding in a bath
oh my god this is a lot harder than I
thought ok this is crazy
I almost smoked a cigarette right now by
accident I literally forgot rocky told
me to keep packing my my pocket all the
time so I pulled my pack I literally
pulled and put in my lips and I'm like
okay hold up alright I put it back and I
start reading and reading the things
that I have to read I'm a nicotine
addict I want to smoke I can smoke I
don't have to stop think about your
benefits it helped me to kind of like
calm down but I was just glad glad that
I stopped that was a very very very
close call
here we are it been two weeks and I
haven't smoked a cigarette and I'm very
proud I really wanted to quit smokin
when I started the process whenever I
would have these sessions with him I
would always say to myself like this is
not gonna happen this is not gonna
happen that's not gonna happen
eventually I got to the point where I'm
like I'm gonna do this I have to do it
just to see what is the difference the
first four days I think weren't the
hardest after two weeks of non smoking I
literally feel my body has cleared up I
was able to kind of like think about
cigarettes whenever I have the thought I
still have the urges I wanted to smoke
but something in me just don't want to
and I think I just want to see the
difference I just wanted to see what
would happen if I didn't smoke he made
me think of it just give yourself a
chance give yourself one chance to see
what would happen to your body and I
think I just took it to like okay let me
just see and I think the benefits from
the first night for not smoking
literally made me convinced that like
why do it I think sometimes we don't we
don't give ourselves credit to we don't
believe in ourselves and sometimes we
just need to remind ourselves that we
have it we have it all Sola in our head
we are so powerful and I think we just
need to believe that
[Music]
[Music]